one of las vegas best kept secrets it's
taco business in the front and then taco
party in the back okay chef lenny chin
is here to give us a taste of their
nightly happenings because if you don't
know
now you know mossberg is the place to be
there's
something happening literally every
night of the week
tonight
monday we have ladies night tuesday taco
tuesdays of course wednesdays latin
night
dj's every weekend it's it's always a
party with great food great drinks and
what kind of djs do you guys have
come come by
the ones we're getting on the strip or
you know special
mix you know we we have we have some
that come from the strip and then we
have some more local djs who just they
do a great job for us i love that mixing
it up a little bit right absolutely all
right well besides the vibes and the
parties let's get into the food yes so
we have we have some of our tacos here
the one in the middle this is my
favorite we call it is that like cheetos
yeah
we call it the movie caliente so it's
got
ground-up cheetos it's got a chipotle
sauce it's delicious this is only happy
hour but this is also one of my
favorites this is a jalapeno popper egg
roll
and then actually i'm gonna
since you said
uh-oh this is one of my favorites as
well this is a shot that we have in a
hollowed-out jalapeno look at the
creativity yeah
yeah
wow it's delicious it's a shot it's a
little spicy okay but if you need to
wash it down what i'm not going to do is
take a whole shot right now but i will
taste it
so here this okay yeah this is our
regular margarita this might help you
out a little bit okay wash it down wash
it down got it guys okay now what goes
into the process of creating your drinks
because as you can see they're all very
creative and you know beautiful it's a
lot of trial and error it's a lot of
finding you know
creative different beautiful glassware
like this skull which is one of my
absolute favorites
this sort of
red kind of a marbled effect in there
and then this is this is also one of my
other favorite drinks this is called the
great balls of fire this is a um a spicy
watermelon margarita okay well yeah now
that you say that i'm gonna go ahead and
try it i think i sold you on it and i
think you know the the dark you know
effect here the skull yeah that's kind
of your vibe at moss perfect board
describe the energy there yeah the
lounge in the back is is very dark it's
very sexy lots of roses on the walls
um lots of great
artwork on the walls as well and then
the front it's a little more i won't say
conservative but it you know it's a
quick service
really good food yeah yeah exactly
exactly so when people come in
what are the go-to's what are the fan
favorites what should people order
quesadilla is definitely a fan favorite
so you know we we sat down we did a menu
design and we said okay we have
quesadilla we got cheese how do we get
more cheese so then that's how we do we
have the um the cheese crust on the
outside wow yeah so it's got cheese
melted on the inside cheese crust on the
outside and i'm trying to find another
way to get cheese in there if there's a
third way to find cheese in a quesadilla
i'm going to get it yeah if anybody's
watching and has a trick he needs to
know yeah message me let me know how to
get cheese in there this is also a cool
thing to do with your quesadillas if
you're making them at home absolutely
yeah you just if you do it in a
non-stick pan you just put a little
cheese on the non-stick pan put your
quesadilla right on top you got a little
cheese crunch i like it i like it this i
love my
poor footboard you guys are a friend of
the shows as well um if people are
coming in should they make reservations
how should they do that yeah i would
definitely say make reservations online
um you can call as well we we are busy
you know we're very blessed to be busy
the local support has been amazing but
um yeah i would suggest making a
reservation for sure all right like i
said taco business in the front party in
the back okay las vegas now we'll be
right back
oh excuse me just kidding